difficile de lier un coup de ciseaux et
un sacré coup de jeune pour les trains
régionaux
voici les nouveaux ter des régions lice
alstom construit un reichshoffen en
alsace sur leurs flancs les couleurs de
la nouvelle région et à l'intérieur un
confort qui enthousiasme déjà les
voyageurs
en tout cas je trouve être un très beau
et c'est très agréable de circuler dans
des trains
mais pour la toux des heures c'est pas
suffisant faudra moines toutes les demi
heures après ce serait bien ce serait
bien pour nous et le 30 bal très bien
c'est très bien j'aime la qualité des
trains je suis très satisfaite et puget
une carte bourgogne liberté et ça me
revient beaucoup moins cher qu bac en
voiture une politique tarifaire présenté
comme attractive un investissement
conséquent sur le matériel neuf près de
400 millions depuis 2013 la région mise
sur des terres fiable et séduisant pour
empêcher les fermetures des lignes les
plus fragiles
aucune de ces lignes n'est menacée
aujourd'hui mais vous savez il n'ya
jamais de menaces quand il ya de la
fréquentation
donc ce qu'il faut c'est que le service
qui est rendue soit excellent à tous
points de vue
d'un point de vue matériel effectivement
avec des bonnes rame comme celle
d'aujourd'hui
et puis du point de vue du service
offert sur les distributions de billets
et en gare et à bord des crampes
une pierre dans le jardin de la sncf qui
prévoit la fermeture d'une vingtaine de
biche et dans la région
nous essayons d'avoir une offre adaptée
avec des coûts maîtrisés soit une offre
de vente en garde guichet ou
distributeurs de billets régionaux et
nous avons aussi maintenant une offre de
vente de billets en dehors de nos gars
sur les lieux de vie dans les communes
les marchés les bureaux de tabac
désormais 18 régiolis sillonnent la
bourgogne franche comté il y en aura 24
ans en 2020 pour emmener les voyageurs
là où ils le veulent
un slogan est une promesse à tenir